now troy um you wanted to share your
oscar nomination with the deaf community
and i
in all my reading and research thought
you were so incredibly ingratiating and
sharing
of this extraordinary moment in your
life
to just open it up to everyone else and
we have several people in our audience
including students from the new york
school for the deaf
and we have one gentleman here
manuel
would you like to share your story with
troy and marley
he's asking may i stand
hi i'm not sure if you remember me but i
remember you when you came to fanwood
new york school for the deaf and marly i
remember you you've come to the school
quite some time and i'm so excited that
you'll get the nomination and the award
next month
we're definitely excited in the deaf
community we you're inspired us all and
because of you in that movie we want
more thank you and i love you so much
i love the new york school for the deaf
they're it's called fanwood and we love
fanwood
thank you so much manuel for your
beautiful words and may i ask you guys
as a last question
did you know
while you were making this film
that it would
literally make history
yes
yes
yes and
2 000
2 000 and it's historic too
well i mean while we were shooting the
film i told troy i said
this is good stuff
i mean i'm going to be on my best
behavior with my language here i could
have said something else but anyway um
no
this is i i knew that this is something
that
that would be an eye-opener for everyone
for the majority of people out there
watching this film they would be amazed
from it
and yeah
i knew it
and my wife who is a teacher of asl she
teaches asl classes and her students had
a little bit of an attitude and weren't
coming to class and weren't doing their
homework or weren't studying and then
they found out that her husband was
nominated for an oscar and all these
kids changed their behavior suddenly
respected my wife and started studying
[Applause]
it made my wife's life so much easier as
a teacher how cool thank you
well
i cannot thank you enough i have been
waiting and anticipating this
conversation and it truly is one of my
favorite films and it is one of my
daughter and i's favorite films now
so thank you for putting this out into
the world
i feel like from the scene also
when she's singing
that i need to read people's faces more
and the way we
realize
um a pivotal moment of someone's life
is to see and recognize the joy
that our children are bringing to people
and how to help foster that
and it was a very awakening lesson for
me
amelia jones who played that role of our
daughter is just i mean i don't know if
there's a right word but she's
the gem of all gems
and
i mean she's such a talented actress
someone who
played so many i mean she had so many
hats during the making of this film
and daniel durant who played uh leo in
the film our son the four of us together
just melded as actors we trusted each
other and
had a lot of fun
it was hard work
but at the end we were very grateful and
grateful to be sitting here and sharing
this story with you and everybody about
our wonderful journey well i i'm so
excited
i celebrate you marley i love you troy
i'm so happy to finally make your
acquaintance and i will happily beg for
more conversations with you anytime
definitely
oh my goodness everybody um thank you
marley choi thank you jack and justin so
much jack i've known you again as long
as i've known marley um and i'm so happy
to make your acquaintance justin um coda
is available to stream now on apple tv
plus and be sure to watch the 94th
academy awards this sunday march 27th on
abc
i will be cheering you on
[Music]
you